80 j'étais persuadé qu'en tremblé puis
en 1987 j'ai changé d'idée
c'était marie josée lebel 1981 1987 1991
défi autobiographique où vous plongeant
plus dans le côté de tout obscur de
votre personnel
s'il en est un oui vous allez vous avez
voulu aller jusqu'où avec 1981 le plus
jusqu'où la naïveté peut m'amener le
plus loin possible cette naïveté que
j'ai du jeu il est moins évident mais
maintenant c'est de croire que le quelqu
un qu une personne qui est fait pour toi
complètement avec qui se porte à vis des
crevettes des recrues meriem bernard
était la femme de ma vie
c'est peut-être la naïveté du débit la
vingtaine qui a commencé à se compliquer
en simonet aussi effet les plus patients
vont remarquer qu'à la toute fin du
générique de 1991 vous remercie hubert
reeves rose le premier qui suivait le
point félicitations l'aimez vous le
remercie de vous avoir poussé à dire qui
vous êtes
oui comment s'est passé le passage du
flambeau loi illustre professeur de
scénarisation du moyen 91
donc j'avais suivi de cours en 90
j'étais d'accord avec tout ce qui a mené
mais vraiment peur de lui un peu aussi
parce qu'il y était très je pense qu'ils
étaient peut-être un peu usée par le
nombre de congrès denis pérennité comme
tanner qui voulait qu'il voulait pas de
quoi dans sa classe les gens arrivent
quelque chose de bon geste parfait qui
nous brasser beaucoup des fois qu'ils
aimaient pas les gens qui arrivent avec
des histoires empruntées il sera le
comprends moins 80 les choses des codes
permettant à s'élancer l'équipement
grandry réduire du premier star wars ça
nous avons beaucoup marqué que je
trouvais c'était vraiment comme epinal
qu'une loi et ils courage de dire qui il
visait
incluant beaucoup vos défauts c'est là
que ça se passe puis à l'époque je les
comprimés je n'ai pas impliqué c'est
plus tard je puis quand je commence à
écrire sérieusement à 30 ans mais n'est
pas que j'étais encore avait encore des
réflexes à me protéger
c'est l'autre écrit - beat combat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une question qui me titille oui
l'ambiance de vos films
il ya de grandes chansons oui et ce
stand en 1986
oui dans 1991 like a rolling stone de
bob dylan
oui combien ça coûte utiliser un tel
rejet jamais rien acheter des t-shirts
dragueur bolide no borders c'était mon
achat avis j'aurais acheté une très
belle voiture ou une maison avec son
hymne
alors y'a pas
[Musique]
non mais c'était là j'étais très
surprise 18 à bord mais dit oui à
condition tout de suite ou puisse
écouter ça coûtait charge plus je pense
je préfère pour dire qu'on veut mais on
parle de montants
[Musique]
il m'a appelé deux noms il sait c'est
son agent je sais plus comment ça pour
sa compagnie de disques habituellement
qui se prononcent pour artistes des fois
j'ai des chansons d'autres asexué
malchance au jdj 87 ça a été un beau
bordel julie d'une toupie touchable pas
passer du tout mais j'hésite le plâtre
le message est lancé à bono
si jamais monotone regarde j'ai pas fini
avec toi tu vas trouver combien chez les
intellos une femme c'est minimum 500
litres
avant cet entretien j'ai revu pour la
troisième fois québec montréal parce que
c'est un film qui a bien vieilli
est ce qu est ce que vous aimeriez de
films et à nouveau on a commis une
petite erreur avec ce film le sait qu'on
a un peu tourné en mini dv qui a pour ce
que c'est à peu près à l'époque c'était
la caméra mode accessible de jeu pour
l'a45 médard puis comme on a vu ce film
à la fin entièrement dans des voitures
puis que ça va être complexe à réaliser
on s'était dit qu'on invite plusieurs
caméras puis blanc ça nous a aidés sauf
que c'est une qualité qu'une limite sur
un écran comme ici cinémathèque ça peut
passer encore et pas trop grand mais
next on a un super méga plex une image
en souffrir c'est donc ce oui j'aimerais
leur fils mais je sais pas ça me
tenterait tant que ça est ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir une suite
québec - on en a parlé au régime je fait
buteur juste arrêter cette question là
je ne sais pas c'est vraiment un grand
point d'interrogation c'est par pur
plaisir pour l'instant ce que tu y
retournes jeunes aujourd'hui - peut-être
- gauvin finir et massa avait parce
qu'on retrouve texte et c'est sûr parce
qu'il était un peu plus d'entrain mike
goût de tous c'est un film sa
communication et la communication
d'époque détermine plein de choses dans
ce milieu tout comme 91
ce film n'aurait pas pu exister s'est
passé c'était passé semaine dernière
parce que tous les problèmes sont venus
du fait que j'étais isolée incapable de
communiquer de personnes principalement
que l'être aimé danser mena donc voilà
ça se passe différemment
ricardo trogi merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup